being warming up
warm up clap you gotta have a warm hi
hey guys I'm great
Alba hello I'm Jesse look at orto Luka
Tuerto don't forget it so Jesse look at
orto is one of the hosts of the channel
sweet eats if you want healthy food that
is also quite tasty in your mouth sweets
eg yo girl yep we are your girls so on a
totally related video we're gonna do a
video about top 5 unknowns - true scary
sleepover stories how often are you
having like you know a cupcake or a
cookie and when you're having a
sleepover all the time sweets
we got your bat C connected it made it I
made it necessary for you to be here
anyway is a great channel you're seeing
the top 5 unknowns nope so usually top 5
Alexa your scariest ready to marry
you see that these are two stories that
was sent - why me - gate 15 at gmail.com
thanks to the amonst in 1604 the stories
go
hello my name is Arianna and I live in
Istanbul Arizona we have moved here
about five years ago and I lived off in
3 different places about 2 years ago we
had moved to a second location
a small Shirley lighthouse that we
purchased at a very low price and would
seem to be a very shady neighborhood one
night while getting used to the house we
had invited some friends over just for
fun since I was barely 10 they decided
to bring over some of their kids to keep
me company okay two little girls around
three or four and one that was the same
ages mean slept over that night when
their parents got too drunk to drive
that night around 3:00 in the morning I
woke up to get something to drink I
quietly made my way out of the room to
not wake up the girls in that house my
room was down the hallway and right
beside it was our bathroom my room also
had a door in it that was connected to
the bathroom anyways as I turn on the
tap to fill up my cup with water I
glanced down the hallway and see a
little girl she was just a blur to me
considering I forgot to wear my glasses
from the shining I smiled thinking it
was one of the girls who were playing
with me earlier I told her to go back to
bed saying it was really late she slowly
turns around and books it and runs into
the bathroom shutting the door I went
considering the door made a loud
slamming noise I waited for my parents
to come storming into the kitchen but
then I realized that when they fall
asleep drunk nothing wakes them up I
psyched and walked down the hallway to
check on the girl as I reached for the
knock on the door I found it to be
locked
I then heard a groaning sound coming
from the bathroom shakily made my way
into the room to access the door in
there pondering whine hoping that she
forgot to lock this one as I reached
open the door I still a glance at the
sleeping girls that's when I noticed
that they were all sleeping soundly my
hand started to tremble as the groaning
voice became louder I've debated on
whether or not I should open the door
when I was about to come to a conclusion
to groaning stop I opened the door to
find nothing inside but the
small of what I assumed to be rotten
flesh I snuck into my parents room by at
night and crawled into that battle of
thumb for I was not going to sleep in
that room about a year later I revealed
my story to my parents who they
questioned the landlord about it he then
told us that he rented us the house at
such a low price because it was built
over a graveyard where little girl was
frozen to death when I was around the
age of seven I lived in Yorkshire in
England with my mom and dad Chris
revealed one night I had a sleepover
with her friend I was in bed and she had
a blow-up air bed on the floor next to
my bed we stayed up fairly late for two
children our age and we finally fell
asleep at around 11 p.m.
bear in mind I'm not bent over my house
was on the top floor I remember waking
up at around 3 a.m. to the sound of
movement i sat bolt upright in my bed
wondering what I just heard I looked
towards on my friend was sleeping in
notice that she was also sad a bulldog
right but unlike me she was rocking back
and forth I called her name but she
either seemed to ignore me or she hadn't
heard me I reached out her and shook her
but she still kept Rocking
she never done anything like this before
I shrugged it off and it seemed that she
was trying to scare me and went back to
sleep
I then awoke again this time I looked at
my clock and it was nearing 40 M
I heard movements again I looked at the
blow-up air bed but this time my friend
was no longer sad or laying there I
rubbed my eyes and looked around the
room feeling slightly worried I noticed
that my friend stood by my window I'll
stick it to myself what was she doing
what was she there later I shook her arm
again this time saying what are you
doing if you're trying to scare me it's
not working stop it and go to bed but
she seemed to be completely ignoring me
I followed the directions of her eyes to
see what she was looking at and then I
saw it by the garage I had and the front
part of my house separate to my house
hiding around the corner of the bridge
walls was a little boy who looked to be
a little younger than me and my use
looking straight into my room window
straight into my eyes as if he was
looking at me I panicked backed away ran
into my bed and left under the covers I
felt safer under my blankets and stayed
there I met frozen fried until I
eventually exhausted myself to sleep
when I woke up later that morning I
looked at the air bed next to my bed and
my friend was fast asleep in it I woke
her up and asked her which was playing
out during the night and she seemed
confused and upset that I was angry at
her and she seemed to have no idea of
the events that took place so instead of
telling her about the little boy that I
saw I left that part out and I didn't
say anything to this day I'm still not
sure what took place that night but if
it was just her playing childish prank
on me then what's the answer behind the
little mysterious boy that was hiding
behind the wall thanks again to both DN
Monsta 1600 for the stories if you have
any scary stories mmm that's my first
time checking out one of their story
videos I usually watch like their top 5
instead I like those stories I believe
in like spirits and ghosts and stuff do
you
yeah absolutely yeah I do I think it's
real I believe in demons and they're
actually seeing a demon
I'm trying to see demon why would you do
that I grew up Catholic you know I'm
right
I don't consider myself a Catholic
anymore but it's been instilled in me of
how I do believe in like spirits and
demons I don't know people just go crazy
when an exorcism happens but pull these
[ __ ] sometimes they look [ __ ] real if
you watch like one of the documentaries
about it or something yeah looks like
the contrary it's like the conjuring
it's 100% accurate player which progress
Blair wakes 1 percent accurate based on
a true story that was found footage
refractor 1 oh yeah they built it where
a girl was frozen so it sounds like they
built it on a burial ground and then
some girl froze to death or she was
intentionally frozen in the house
scary I wonder if she was intentionally
frozen maybe that's why she was like
messing with people you know when I was
really young and we would go to a price
Club which is now known as Costco they
have like these giant freezers you know
yeah refrigerators whatever and my dad
and brother would like to go inside them
and then close the door huh it's that
bit there and close the door and it was
like funny because they were in there so
me that's just what happened with a
little girl now maybe maybe she was
hiding maybe she was hiding she got
stuck and then she froze and then the
parents were like ah this is because
it's built on a burial ground while our
parenting skills were so bad oh man they
left must be the reason
speculation people speculation you never
know where it's gonna take you but it
might lead you to the truth and I think
we're there
truth the answer is just [ __ ] around
a little girl yeah little Josie I think
in the second one though I don't think
his friend was messing with him the
little boy yeah I think the girl who was
standing at the window or whatever you
know what freaks me out to sleep walking
like when you sleepwalker you see
someone sleepwalk he's someone's
sleepwalking cuz they don't remember so
maybe that's what she was doing and
while the boy was like possessing her
out there I don't know
as he said there was a little boy
outside i'm when i sleepwalk i I
normally like sometimes I'm really good
at stretching when I'm sleeping well so
you're not like one of the like I break
into a separate stepbrothers no no I
wake up I don't like OFI no I good every
time I think I'm awake but I just break
in like an hour stretch I'm gonna wake
up relaxed yeah lead a really good life
you know I see I just I hope to sleep
walk that or I pee on things
sounds like my boy
you know your boyfriend I'll get along
really well I think you guys would I
like to sleepwalk with him get to know
him on a real lovely enough I think you
would be best friends after that
especially when I was really young I had
a dream that I sleepwalk that I walked
into the bathroom and the kitchen
started peeing in the trash and my
brother was washing the dishes oh my
gosh then I woke up and found out I
really did it was my dad who was washing
the dishes piss he was really upset
because he didn't realize I was sleeping
oh yeah he thought I was just like haha
it was an accident
yeah I [ __ ] on the carpet and blame it
on sleepwalking
where's this video going yeah it's a
Rutter sleep volume up at the burial
ground story though I heard that I was
like it's kind of cliche yeah that it
was built on a burial badly that really
happens I'm totally crass I mean it
modesty many people have died yeah where
are they in the ground burn walls what
little skull well it's not walls what it
is called um do we know what you're
trying to refer to where they put their
um their that's right they put if they
have like a wall
I mean people die so they're obviously
in the ground so you have to build on
top of that eventually that's not true
right I would love to live on on top of
a burial ground I'm not sure that I
would love it maybe I want to live on a
burial ground I'm like one of those
stories of like this father went crazy
like murderers like all of his family I
that would be and then you have like hey
there's a 13 year old boys hanging out
with my younger sister right now early
what season was
American or straight line someone yeah
per season I love that one
gee okay good we're gonna say genius
yeah I got a G well Mel Gibson if you're
watching I hope you enjoyed this video
you can subscribe today people become a
real reject that's what I say sometimes
Jesse look at old Horto Oh
Tuerto yes the clapping large syllables
Luca torch for Luca torte okay it's from
the channel yeah he goes follow her on
Instagram I'm on Twitter Instagram and
Facebook calm slash the real rejects the
Greg Alba promotion for myself
yeah anyway this is Jess's last video
with us and it's my say Jess I think he
did an amazing job
thank you so much he's so much fun being
here really yeah a good time I had a
great time full time I'm ready that I've
been boring you know never you're the
least boring person that's so speedy you
mean your boyfriend right yes yes
obviously
can we can't wait we love at first sight
and I see a photo I won't put it on the
Internet yeah oh he's a handsome devil
he's so handsome he's handsome he he has
a nice suit too he knows what he does
how to rock that suit yeah boy
gentlemen you're in competition with
this guy
I'm warning you he's a cutie I can't
wait to meet him I'm gonna look so cool
when I go out in public but so cool so
cool you guys a little you guys will
complement I tell you girls ever yeah
what does he play not at home so I don't
know what does that mean looks like what
every my daughter like friends houses
like he leaves hopefully pretty okay
that's friendly like breeze oh my games
over okay good I play these here please
just won't let me